do you ever see someone in their early
20s more mature than someone in their
40s or 50s you know you hear the term
indigo children which some people it's a
very controversial term because but but
there's been you know this sort of rise
of these indigo children who are highly
intuitive and very bright and advanced
the indigo part comes from well the
purple is sort of represents like
empathy and psychic abilities
so it's a very woowoo sort of thing and
but there are these indigo children do
you ever see where there's some that are
just stepped foot in the world and
somehow they have this old soul where as
50 year olds still teenagers it's
interesting what an interesting question
and an interesting time to ask me that
question because we are as we are
recording this we happen here at UCLA to
be in the the final throes of the
admissions process the application
process you know people applying to the
program we're now in the interview
process we and we get hundreds and
hundreds of applications for the for the
program between three and four hundred
applications and there are only a couple
of dozen slots in the program and they
will only get about because it's a
daunting enterprise to apply people
don't cavalierly apply it's not like you
check off the box stuff and you send it
in you have to do a whole lot of work
and you have to pay a substantial fee
just to apply and that means that
there's a lot of self selection that
goes on a lot of people who are not
really serious don't don't apply so
we've got hundreds of applications out
of which maybe eight or ten are just no
good all the rest of pretty good and
then there'll be a hundred and fifty
let's say that it just blindingly good
we'll talk to half of those people and
admit one-third of those whom we
actually interview so we're finally
we're in the interviewing process now
and I just interviewed a guy yesterday
very young and yet he was so mature like
you say he had actually researched me
I knew all of my books and had actually
tracked down my first book which is a
fairly obscure novel and I thought that
was amazingly mature thing for for young
such a young person to do very
circumspect and wise you can bet we'll
it met this guy again not not sewing on
the basis of that but the fact the fact
that he actually did some research and
thought about how he would come across
and so on it bodes well
you